قبل المونديال اذا سالنا اي مشجع عن
توقعاتي في حال قابل المنتخب المغربي
نظيره الفرنسي في كاس العالم كان حتما
سيرجح كافه الديوك للفوز باللقاء لكن
اليوم نحن في نصف النهائي وبعد ما اقصى
الاسود البرتغال وقبلها اسبانيا وهزمت
بلجيكا تدخل المباراه بحسابات مختلفه ولا
اراده غير اراده الفارس تصريحات وليد
الرجراجي مدرب المغرب تحمل نبره ايجابيه
منذ بدء المونديال يتحدث عن تغيير عقليه
لاعبين وتعديل نظره مشاركتهم في البطوله
لانه يدخل مباراه فرنسا والعين على
المباراه نهائيا
اليوم الموعد المنتظر على ملعب البيت
قلوبنا مع المغرب ونقول اللاعبين
طمعنا في اللقب بسببكم اذهب ولا تبخلوا
بقطرتي ومهما كانت النتيجه
[موسيقى]
قاد فرنسا
وحدهم المدرب المغربي يقول الانتقادات
اداءه وقله استحواذ فريقه نابعه من
الانزعاج بسبب وصول منتخب افريقي لنصف
النهائي مدرب فرنسا يتحدث بتواضع ايضا عن
المغرب ويرى انهم يستحقون مكان التي وصل
اليها في المونديال واقر بصعوبه التسجيل
امامهم وذلك بسبب صلبتهم الدفاعيه لكنه
سيحاول حل ذلك رغم انه قاد منتخبه لصعود
منصه التكوير في مونديال السابق الا انه
قد يصبح ضحيه جديده في حال خسارته امام
المغرب وربما يواجه شبح الايقال على غرار
روبيرتوماتيزم
اسبانيا من المغرب سالنا جماهير الاسود
لا تقولوا ما جينا هات
الفرحه تح
زن
الجمهور المغربي
[موسيقى]
اولادنا رجال سبوع رايت ناره مرفوعه ان
شاء الله
غربنا واسرار دراري غيتقاتلوا بحال دارو
مع الماتش البرتغال ان شاء الله واحد
لزيرو‬»
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله يا رب الله
يارب الله
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك من جديد معنا امس لما
سئل المدرب الفرنسي
اجد صعوبه في الدفاع المغربي في صلابه
الدفاع المغربي لكن ساجد له حلا يعني لم
يتلقى الدفاع المغربي الا هدفا واحدا وكان
معاكسه في الممتعه تقيمك للفريقين في نصف
النهائي صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادين
يعني شو ما احلاها يعني الاجواء اليوم انه
في الدوري نصف النهائي يعني العالم العربي
يتابع على المباراه
كبير ليس كمتفرج وانما كان عنصر فاعل في
هذا الحدث العالمي الكبير طبعا المنتخب
المغربي اليوم احسن سفير الكره العربيه
والافريقيه في هذا الحدث همم يعني كلام
المدرب الفرنسي عن المنتخب المغربي المهم
جدا يعكس قيمه هذا المنتخب الذي اصبح من
المنتخبات العالميه افضل اربع منتخبات على
مستوى العالم هو المنتخب المغربي الحديث
عن قوه ال- الدفاع المنتخب المغربي
بالتاكيد هذا عامل مهم جدا كان هو افضل خط
دفاع الى ال- والى الان يزال الى يزال او
افضل خد دفاع فهذا ما يؤكد طبعا حيره همم
المدرب الفرنسي جديد شو كيف سيواجه هذا
الخط المتماسك للامانه الدفاع المنتخب
المغربي ليس فقط مدافعين اربع لاعبين في
خط الخلفي وحارس وانما ايضا يبدا من اول
مهاجم فريق مقاتل فريق كتله واحده وهذا ما
يجعله لغز محيرا للمدربين طيب
حمير على المقلب الاخر في مبابي وحكيمه
اصدقاء ومع بعض في نفس الفريق باريس سان
جيرمان اليوم هل هذا سيعقد او يسهل بان كل
طرف يفهم الاخر سيكشف اسراره سيفك يعرف
كيف يفكر في اللعبه
يعني سبحان الله يعني من الاشياء الطريفه
التي يعني حصلت ان فيديو نشرهم بافي يعني
خلال معسكر باريس سان جيرمان في همم
الدوحه قبل الانتقاد كاس العالم همم كان
في نفس ملعب المباراه وقال اللي همم سوف
نفوز على تونس ولم يفوز على تونس طبعا
المنتخب الفرنسي ثم سوف نفوز على المنتخب
المغرب واسف صديقي هذا هو كره القدم ولابد
ان نفوز عليك اجابه حكيمي سوف نفوز عليكم
نحن همم هذه المؤشرات الايجابيه تعكس طبعا
في النهايه همم العلاقه الحميميه والقويه
جدا بين حكيم وهمبابي همم علاقه همم يعني
همم تطورت لما التحق اشرف حكيمي في باريس
سان جيرمان وشوفنا يعني انه يتبادلان
الزياره وعلى التهاني هو علاقه قويه اليوم
داخل الملعب من الصدف ايضا ان المدافع ال-
ال- البكرايت يعني اشرف حكيمي سوف يكون في
مهمه مراقبه اقوى اقوى مهاجم في البطوله
وهداف وهو كده يعني مهمه صعبه مهمه سوف
تلفت ال- انتباه لكل ال- ال- الجماهير
وكاميرات التلفزيونات سوف تكون مركز على
هذا الثنائي في تحركتهما وسوف تكون يعني
همم مواقف جميله وصعبه كثير يعني لعب سريع
جدا
هداف لو امكانيه كبيره وهمم يعني قادر على
الفوز بجائزه همم هداف البطوله في هذا
المونديال لكن ايضا اشرف حكيمي شاهدنا
مستوى متطور جدا في هذه البطوله على عكس
باريس سان جيرمان ويقدمه في كاس العالم مع
المنتخب الامن المغربي
موسى جيد حتى الان همم تقييم الفريقين
بحسب النسب الاليه اظهرت مستويات عاليه في
الدفاع في الاستحواذ على الكره في الهجمات
المرتده وفرص التسجيل لمن ترجح الكفه
المغرب
شخصيا يعني اداء المنتخب المغربي وما
شاهدناه من تكثل دفاعي وشاهدناه من نضج
تكتيكي وقدره على تطبيق العديد من الرسوم
التكتيكيه خلال المباراه
والرغبه الكبيره في تحقيق ما يمكن بعد ما
يمكن في هذا المونديال يجعل المتفائل ان
المنتخب المغربي اليوم سوف يكون مفاجاه
ساره نعم المباريات الماضيه كان استحقاق
وصول المنتخب
لكن اليوم سوف تكون همم تكون مفاجاه يعني
مستحقه المنتخب المغربي المباراه
انصحها التعبير لكل من الفريقين التي قد
يستفيد منها كل منهما بالنسبه للمنتخب
الفرنسي اقوى خط هجوم تقريبا يعني يملك
اسلحه خطيره جدا مبابي وسرعاته وانطلاقاته
ايضا غريزمان ايضا ديمبلي عثمان ديمبلي
يعني لاعبين خطيرين جدا على مستوى الهجوم
وبامكانياتهم الفنيه بامكانهم اختراق اي
دفاع لكن على مستوى الدفاع هناك بعض ثغرات
خاصه لما يتقدم المنتخب الفرنسي والمنتخب
الفرنسي يلعب دائما الهجوم وان يعني بنفس
يعني هجومي يؤدي في هذا المندي المنتخب
المغربي يعني المنتخب كتله واحده منسجم
يعني على الاطراف يعني داخل خط الوسط هناك
لاعبين ارتكاز قادرين على افتكاك اي كوره
اي مساحه
لكن يعني المنتخب المغربي وهو همم
الاستفاده من الهجمات المرتده شاهدنا امام
همم اسبانيا امام البرتغال الكثير من
الانفرادات التي اضاعها مهاجمون للمنتخب
المغربي وهذا يمكن ان لا يتكرر كثيره امام
فرنسا وفي اللعب الفرنسي كمان سيلعب ضد
منتخب زوجته يعني بلاد زوجته في المغرب
لاعب فرنسي عثمان ديمبلي متزوج
على فكره
هو من مواليد فرنسا